[Music]
hello and welcome in the last video
about transformers we found out how the
transformer architecture works in this
video you will find out how the
transformer architecture can process
images and texts simultaneously but
let's not spoil everything already and
start with the beginning the transformer
architecture has proven to be very
impactful in natural language processing
but what can be even cooler than looking
at only text while looking at text and
images at the same time and because we
speak about two different input types
being processed by a machine learning
algorithm we are here speaking about
multimodal learning okay but what does
this have to do with transformers well
they can be applied to multimodal
problems too like for integrating vision
and language in an unified model how
cool is that this kind of model has been
proposed almost simultaneously by a
number of different researchers all
these papers proposed almost
concurrently the same base model of
course with some slight variations but
with the same basic idea they process
language and images simultaneously with
the transformer architecture and most
often the transformer architecture
chosen is Burtt bi-directional version
of the transformer into it they add a
capability of processing visual input in
the same time with language input we
will not discuss all of these papers
here you can find a comprehensive list
of most of them linked below in the
description discussing all these papers
would not only take a while but because
of the high topic overlap it would be
also quite redundant instead miss coffee
bean shows her favorite paper by the
Facebook AI team she chose this one over
all others because they
provided the code pays which is not only
available for everyone but also clean
and maintained in the following we will
discuss first how image and language are
integrated at once in the birth
transformer model and second about the
training procedure which I would like to
call your pre trained ception
okay so let's dive into it from now on
we will call this the transformer module
which is formed like we have explained
in the last video so it is formed of the
multi-head self attention layer the
feed-forward layers in the residual
connections acting like information
highways between them so this everything
now is the transformer module the trick
here is to train the model on text image
pairs like images and their captions the
text part is easy to explain because it
is exactly like what the usual pert
architecture does we feeds the word or
tokens in vector representation together
after we added the positional embeddings
or identifiers to these vectors so our
model is informed about the word order
by these positional embeddings and we
feed this to our usual transformer
module to process the text now let's put
the text part to the side a little bit
and see what we can do on the image side
we also have to somehow transform our
image into a vector sequence format
because the transformer is specialized
for exactly this sequences but but how
well the idea is if we combine vision
and language anyway why not have an
architecture that specializes on finding
correspondences between words and image
regions regions there we said it let's
extract such image regions and order
them in an arbitrary sequence we can
represent each region by a vector
by employing CNN based neural network
that we borrow from computer vision good
we got this far now the idea is to
really compute these correspondences
between image regions and the text by
adding the layers that to this
computation with Co attention now what
does Co attention mean until now we had
attention we had self attention now we
have Co attention well while the usual
transformer modules in green look only
at their own branch for computing
attention through self attention the
cool attention modules in blue are
looking also at the other branch to
compute important scores between images
and text and vice versa
so with Co attention the image computes
attention based on the text and vice
versa for refinement we add then another
layer of Transformers and another Co
attention layer and another transformer
module and another and you get it the
deeper the better we are doing deep
learning here huh
now the question is how do we end this
how do we get to our output and what is
our output anyway well it depends what
we train our network to do it can be
just a multi-layer perceptron followed
by a soft max for getting out of score
for example for the similarity between
image and text this is really dependent
on the task and the whole network can
have many of these output heads one for
each task it is trained on and sometimes
it is trained also in parallel on many
different tasks so naturally we have to
discuss what with train this monster to
do in this pre train inception how I
like to call it it is a very interesting
part because like in every inception we
have multiple stages and here we are
ready to explain what stage one is we do
pre training at this first stage on the
text side end on the image side but
separately for the text we have birds
trained on huge amounts of English text
so we take that birth weights and use
them here to initialize our word modules
then the image side has to be also pre
trained to produce useful features from
the images here in the Wilbert paper
they have used our faster our CNN
architecture useful in object detection
for computer vision for the second stage
of pre-training the wilpert paper uses
their conceptual captions data set they
use this one and no other because it is
huge and contains images and their
captions and on this conceptual captions
data set they train the network that was
already trained on english text
welder with the following objectives one
task is to predict labels for what the
image regions might be another training
task is also followed at this stage
which is masked word prediction like in
the classical transformer so here the
model would ideally predict mountain
because it knows from the image through
Co attention layers
what should fall into that place best
and we are already at a training stage
number three where the same model that
at stage one learned to process images
and text separately at stage two
combines them and understands the
relations between text and image and is
now ready to be trained to solve a task
involving both textual and visual
modalities such tasks are for example
visual question and answering where the
model is given an image and the question
and it has to provide the right answer
to the question based on the image
Wilbert not only beat the state of the
art at the time of publication on this
task but by a large margin visual
common-sense reasoning is the better
brother of visual question and answering
where the system has to provide the
answer to the question but also to give
the reason for the answer and ideally
this reason is you know reasoning about
a problem and is not giving tautological
ination like this picture is a mountain
because it is a mountain but rather an
explanation that this image depicts a
mountain because if the mountain is
taller than the horizon for example here
Wilbert also achieved state of the art
by a large margin image retrieval is the
task where given a caption of an image
the model has to select the right image
it is described by the caption from a
pool of many other images and surprise
surprise state of the art again
kohrville Burt phrase grounding is a
more fine-grained task but also perfect
for Wilbert that thanks to the Coe
attention layers learns relationships
between image regions and words because
here in this task given a phrase in the
caption like mountain the system has to
identify the region that this phrase
refers to and yes again state of the art
for Wilbert so now that you have seen
training in so many stages first on text
on images then on text and images and
you have seen how this has helped
Wilbert to perform so well on many
downstream tasks we can sell free say
that is whole pre-trained ception
or you know different stages or
strategies to pre train the model before
being applied and trained further on a
downstream task is really really helpful
and because these pre training
strategies are so cool we will spend the
whole next video only about this we will
discuss different pre training
strategies because Wilbert follows only
two of the pre training strategies but
there are others propose in other papers
about multimodal transformers so we will
see these strategies in the next video
and not only strategies for multimodal
transformers but also for the pure
language bird see you then
[Music]
you
[Music]